the best founders i found are the ones
who are very long-term thinkers so even
decisions that maybe they shouldn't care
that much about early on they fix it on
because they are not building a house
they're putting bricks in the foundation
of a skyscraper at least in their minds
and so what you're looking for is
looking for someone who knows the space
well who understands how difficult it's
going to be but doesn't care because
they're they just love whatever they're
doing they're into it
and they commit to it for the long haul
so you know passion and vision alone are
not enough yeah i think steve case said
that vision without an execution is a
hallucination
execution alone isn't enough and then
unfortunately at least in technology
business there's a lot of luck required
right place right time market forces
timing uh you know regulatory action
against or pro so there's a lot of
things that control where the platforms
are shifting what open source efforts
show up so you can never predict the
outside successes but what you can
predict the failures you can say oh this
person doesn't know this field at all
their way out of their death or this
person they're a short-term thinker
they're not going to last
the game they're not going to they have
to go as far as needed
because as i was saying there are no new
ideas all the ideas have been thought of
but it's about the combination of the
idea plus the execution plus the passion
like steve jobs was a visionary and a
great designer not because he came with
the idea to build a smartphone many
people had tried to build a smartphone
but it's because he had a very high bar
for the design he understood the
manufacturing tolerances and what the
technology was cable and what it wasn't
he could rally the people and the
resources to get it done he actually
didn't care about the financial outcome
he took a dollar salary from apple he
just wanted to see it done and he was
willing to do it for as long as it takes
until it worked
so it's kind of this magic conference of
factors and then the timing in the world
happened to be right the technology was
around and johnny i was there and who
knows how many other factors intersected
to make it happen but just many factors
intersected on his side there were ones
that intersected against him um you know
for example he had particular apple
which was a horribly failing company at
the time a poor guy died of pancreatic
cancer he got taken out early think
about what more he could have created
what more he could have done for the
world
he probably wasn't happy in the whole
process
you know he drove himself to ruin
um so i i think you do have to be
irrationally optimistic to succeed and
passionate uh but you also have to
really know your stuff
uh and
i meet a lot of entrepreneurs rather
short-term thinkers in which case that's
okay it just means this is not the thing
for you right go find the thing you can
commit to for 10 years because that's
how long it's going to take minimum to
get a good outcome and you have to enjoy
the journey because there's no guarantee
on the outcome
and you have to be really really good at
it which means that you probably love it
so much that you're willing to put in
the time before there's even any return
on it
so i think the best founders they have
a deep understanding of the space
they're going into enough to be
contrarian
and they have a deep passion for it so
that they'll just keep working on it and
they have uh execution skills they just
get things done they solve problems
they're capable
i love that
yeah
i don't get to invest with uh angel
founders so i don't but we all deal with
people with similar
you know in business or life if we're
establishing a partnership whether it's
with a customer a supplier
you know a relationship we have similar
concerns about
their short-term thinking and will take
advantage of us and how should we go
about entering that relationship and is
this relationship fragile i think that's
a good way to think about it
one thing i figured out kind of late is
that generally at least in the tech
business in silicon valley great people
have great outcomes you just have to be
patient
uh every person that i met at the
beginning of my career 20 years ago
where i looked and said wow that guy or
that gal is super capable they're so
smart and dedicated blah blah now we'll
just be friends or hang out or whatever
we kind of forgot about them all of them
almost without exception became
extremely successful you just had to
give them a long enough time skill it
never happens in a time scale you want
or they want but it does happen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you